와 바다다
우리 세명이였던 케미
그런걸 위해서
우리 바다에 불렀는데
해수욕장 아니었어요?
전 주소찍고 왔거든요?
이상한 데로 가더라고
뭐 어쩌고 한대요
오늘의 주제
나 맞춰볼게요
수고한 자들이여
놀아라
아 저거 타고?
아 저거 타고 논다고?
아닐거 같은데
뭐야 오
뭐야
메이크 슈카 그레이터기
죄송한데 메이크 그레이터 하신적이 없는데
이거잖아 이거
이거
아 정신을 또 하사불서
상동전자가 방구채
저거 처음 짰을때
잘 안된다는 말이 많으니까
이병철 회장님이 64K 디렘을
그때 만드신때였거든요 처음으로
64키로 행군을 시키셨대요
정신이건 하기 위해서
우리도 2006년이니까
정신을 또 하사불서 이걸로
법문문 차입니다
배치미 준비 끝나고
51포
장전수 박팀장내
3명 배치준비 끝
박팀장등
이게 해군의 군함이군요
이게 오늘 여러분들이 콘텐츠를 진행하게 될
최신의 함정 서울함입니다
저희 이제 서울함은
2,800톤으로
포트폴리오랑 비교를 하면
올웨더 포트폴리오라 할수 있습니다
아 올웨더 포트폴리오라고
하이브리드 추진시스템을 가지고있는데
평소에 기동을 할때는 되게
정습성있게 기동을 하다가
위급 상황이 되면
바다에서 고속 항해를 할 수 있는 개입니다.
해군의 최신의 함정 FFG 소울함입니다.
저는 근데 지금 얘기하면서 약간 좀 이상한 게 뭐냐면
지금 슈카 님이 약간 사단장 포스가 나거든요.
사단장 포스가 나는데 계급이 지금 하사야.
그리고 개미 님이 고인 님 설명해주세요.
막내로 달아줬어요.
실제로 만나니까 하사 달아도 될 만큼 젊으셔서
역시 해군이 최고야. 하사가 막내잖아요.
보통 하사가 몇 살 정도 됩니까? 20대 초등반 정도 됩니까?
기본적으로 이게 현문이라는 겁니다.
구두와 배를 이어주는 하나의 달이라고 보시면 되는데
유유하셔야 할 게 여러분들이 현문의 중간 지점에 가셨을 때
태극기를 향해서 다르게 경례를 해주시면 됩니다.
의식이라고 보시면 됩니까? 의식?
이제 국민과 나라에 대한 어떤
멋있다.
굳은 마음을
가지면 됩니다.
굳은 마음을 가지면 됩니다.
그리고 이제 함정에 승함을 해주시면 될 것 같습니다.
승함하시도록 하겠습니다.
우선 서울함에 오시면 먼저 함장님께 전입신고를 하면서
이제 시작을 하는데
승조 체험 오셨으니까 좀 이따 함장님 오시면 전입신고를 하실 겁니다.
그래서 그거 대상으로 먼저 교육을 해드리겠습니다.
우선 해군에서는 경례 구호를 필승을 사용합니다.
그래서 처음에 차렷 자세에서 필이라고 말씀을 하시고
필.
하고
승을 할 때는 경례를 하면서 승을 하시면 됩니다.
아 오른손을 죄송합니다.
네 각도가 지금 이렇게 되거든요.
이거 어떻게 해보십니까?
아 예 일자로 이렇게 일자로 이해하겠습니다.
이게 일자가 아니라 수아가 자네가 잘하게 이거 맞잖아요.
너무 손목에 애교가 들어가 있어요.
아 옷도 이제 이거 이런 매무새를 좀 정리해 주세요.
죄송합니다.
잘 못 봤습니다.
배도 집어넣어야 되죠?
배도 집어넣어야죠.
거만하지 않게 거만하지 않게 배를 집어넣어야죠.
두 분은 배를 좀 집어넣으시면 될 것 같습니다.
피지컬이어서 어쩔 수 없지.
아예 어떻게 해야 돼.
저 피지컬이라.
이 상태로 이제 한번 연습 실시하겠습니다.
그 함장님께서 여기 앞에 서실 겁니다.
그럼 제가 사회를 보겠습니다.
지금부터 전입신고를 시작하겠습니다.
함장께 대한 경례 하면은 대표자 한 분이 함장께 대하여 경례를 해주시면 됩니다.
그리고 경례를 해주시면 됩니다.
함장께 대하여 경례.
필승.
해주시고 함장님께서 받아주시면 그때 먼저 내리시고 그 다음에 바로 해주시면 됩니다.
바로.
하면 그때 내리시면 됩니다.
박 하사님 뭔가 목소리에 힘이 없는데요.
아 힘 없어요?
공기가 조금 덜 들어간 것 같은데.
나.
알겠습니다.
박하사탄 같아요.
가장 큰 목소리로 해주시면 됩니다.
다시 한번 해보겠습니다.
함장께 대하여 경례.
필승.
받아주시면.
바로.
아니 내가.
이게 뭐예요.
눈이 없습니까.
이런 걸 옛날에 뭐라고 했냐면.
따라해보세요.
문.
완.
제가요?
어 알겠네요.
그래서 검은 거야.
죄송합니다.
저희 단합대회에 왔습니다.
단합대회죠.
응 그니까.
뭐.
하고 악수하실 때 하사님이 최선을 다하겠습니다.
하사님이 최선을 다하겠습니다.
어 여기 잠시만요.
그렇게 하지 마셔야 돼요.
키가 커서 그렇습니다.
네.
이 함대는 보통 싸우면 박살 내겠습니다.
이 입을 제일 많이 해서.
아.
하셔도 그런 것도 있습니다.
하사하시면.
하사하실까?
싸우면 박살 내겠습니다.
네.
하시고.
뭐 조지겠습니다.
이런 건 하면 안 되잖아요.
아 예.
그렇지.
다 조져버렸습니다.
아니 나는 더 하고 싶은데.
그러니까.
박살이 아니야.
강하게.
단어 선택은.
자유롭게 하시면 됩니다.
알겠습니다.
하사 박팀장 조지겠습니다.
자넨 퇴선이야.
아니 다양하게 가야 돼.
박.
손바닥 박.
안녕하십니까.
지금부터 전입 신고를 시작하겠습니다.
함정께 대하여 경례.
필승.
바로.
서울함 1일 승조 체험차 전입.
슈카 친구들 슈카 등 3명.
명 서울함.
2026년 3월 19일부.
이상으로 전입 신고를 마치겠습니다.
함정께 대하여 경례.
박.
필.
승.
바로.
아무튼 오늘 바쁘신데도 이렇게 서울함 찾아주셔서 감사하고.
아닙니다.
네.
감사합니다.
아무튼 그 우리 승조원들한테 건강한 경제관념이 생길 수 있도록 많은 교육 부탁드리고.
또 뭐 요즘 좀 채널을 보니까 모니콤 코믹스의 단합이 많이 좀 문제가 있다는 그런 첩보가 있던데.
열심히 하겠습니다.
오늘 서울함 승조 체험을 계기로.
단합할 수 있는.
그런 계기가 되었으면 좋겠습니다.
예 알겠습니다.
알겠습니다.
다시 한 번 환영합니다.
네.
네 모두들.
반갑습니다.
다시?
뭐 그거 해야 돼요?
아뇨 아뇨.
알겠습니다.
괜찮습니다.
아 저거 무슨 멘트였더라.
아 그래.
저걸 박살내겠습니다.
다 같이 작살내겠습니다.
네.
실수 다섯 번 났어요.
그 짧은 사이에 실수를 몇 번 하는 거예요?
죄송합니다.
여러분들이 하신 훈련은 전투배치 훈련입니다.
먼저 탄약고로 안내해드리도록 하겠습니다.
알겠습니다.
저걸 박살내겠습니다.
이거 보시면 한 사람이 지나가기에도 좋기 때문에 해군에 이제 길 차려라는 문화가 있습니다.
예를 들어서 계급이 다른 두 사람이 만났을 때 지금 제가 계급이 높으니까 제가 앞으로 간다.
이렇게.
이렇게 지나가고 이런 걸 길 차려라고 합니다.
길 차려.
아 왜 그렇게.
막내는 그럼 계속 이러고 있습니까?
네.
거의 이러고.
그럼 이러고 다녀야 되겠습니다.
막내는.
우리같이 막내.
그렇지.
네.
그리고 해군 함정의 좀 독특한 문화가 이제 일몰이 되면은 이제 빛이 창문을 통해 나가려면 저항이 발견될 수도 있기 때문에 이제 밤 되면 이게 등 색깔을 이렇게 빨간색으로.
영화에서 많이 봤어요.
이러면은 밖은 잘 안 나갑니까?
네.
최대한 나가는 빛을 줄이기 위해서요.
와 신기하다.
여기가 여러분들이 장전소 임무를 수행하게 될 5인치 포 상비 탄약고입니다.
5인치는 포탄의 구경이 5인치가 된다는 거예요.
5인치.
상당히 큰 포탄에 속합니다.
진짜 포탄이니까?
네.
진짜 포탄.
떨어뜨리면은 혹시 어떻게 됩니까?
어떡해.
조심해서 해요.
혹시나 혹시나 떨어뜨리면.
탄 자체가 무게가 있기 때문에 떨어뜨리면 발을 다칠 수도 있어서 최대한 조심해주세요.
사장님 조심하세요.
50개 있어요.
우리 과장님.
나보다 고문관이 문제야.
예.
알겠습니다.
네.
들어가 봅시다.
우와 진짜 포탄이야.
전투 배치하게 되면 임무가 이제 잔전수다.
한 분씩 다 잔전수 잔전수 잔전수 하실 겁니다.
저희 대원 중에 한 명이 탄약수가 여러분한테 탄약을 한 발 줄 겁니다.
먼저 장약을 먼저 주시고 발하고 주먹을 이용해서 세게 밀어주시면 잔전이 됩니다.
그다음에 잔전하고 그 다음에 더미.
더미를 이 선반 위에 올려놓고 양손 주먹을 이용해서 세게 밀어주시면 잔전이 됩니다.
이렇게 하면 자동으로 저희 포가 자동화 시스템이기 때문에
자동으로 돌면서 이제 장전되고 그다음에 네.
어떻게 저랬어.
이게 무게가 몇 킬로입니까.
지금 31.75.
31.75킬로.
이거 들 수 있는 사람.
밑에는 17킬로.
17킬로.
이게 아무도 못 들어요 이거.
둘이 합쳐가지고 지금 거의 50킬로 가깝게.
할 수 있습니다.
자신 있습니까.
자신 있습니다.
목소리가 좋습니다.
저를 박살내겠습니다.
박살을 내버리겠습니다.
박살내겠습니다.
실시.
니하사.
그래서 박살내겠나.
니하사 자네 박살나는 거 아니야.
야 근데 이거.
무거워.
또 열 거거든요.
그때는 철모나 시어트.
니하사.
잠깐만 잠깐만.
아저씨 죽는 거 아니야.
괜찮아.
어 신경 좀 줘.
야 잘 들어 잘 들어.
야 잠깐만.
잘 들어.
이건 어떡해.
올려 올려.
야 올려.
잘 나와.
손지면 안 돼.
야 올려 올려.
야 올려.
야.
네 해서 주먹을 밀으시면 됩니다.
셋 다 지금 무게를 느끼고.
쉽습니다.
솜털같이 가깝습니다.
같이 힘을 합치냐 하시셨습니다.
한 손으로 할까 고민했었습니다.
한 손으로 할까.
나중에 실전 총을 전투 배치하게 되면 복장 갖추고 탄약소에서 탄약 인계 받고 여러분들이 직접 장전하시면 됩니다.
또요?
이거 몇 명이 장전합니까?
인원이 많으면 세 네 명이 하는데.
인원이 적을 때는 세 명이나 두 명이서 같이 장전합니다.
방금 하신 훈련이 전투 배치 훈련에 탄약 장전수 임무를 수행하신 거고 임무로 나가는 건 출전 나간다고 표현을 하는데 나가면 매일 하루에 한 번씩 해서 전비 태세를 완비하고 있습니다.
이거 맨날 하루에 한 번씩 하는 거예요?
네 매일매일 하고 있습니다.
전 승조원이 다 합니까?
네 전 다 지금 탄약수만 체험을 하신 건데 배 곳곳에 각자 다 맡은 역할이 있어서 엔진도 있고 포도 있고.
각자의 역할을 한 번씩 하는구나.
네 각자의 다 역할이 붙어서 해야지 전투 배치를 할 수 있습니다.
피우면서 두가리 하는 느낌으로?
뭐니까 이거?
실제로 훈련할 때 하는 방식입니다.
그럼 저희는 어떻게 해야 돼요?
이제 장소를 이동하시면 됩니다.
어 어떡해 무서워.
야 가!
잠깐.
뛰어!
복점 빨리 있습니다.
발품 장사 철봉 어디 넣었습니까?
철봉 갔다 오겠습니다.
갔다 오셨다.
빨리 복점 신속하게 착용합니다.
예 알겠습니다.
다 입었으면 51포 50포 전장수 박팀장들 3명 배치민 준비 끝합니다. 알겠습니까?
배치민 준비 끝나면 보고!
복면 무차합니다. 배치민 준비 끝나면 보고!
준비 끝나면 보고!
배치민 준비 끝나면 보고!
박팀장 준비 끝!
외 3명.
외 3명 준비 끝!
배치민 준비 끝나면 보고!
chair off
박팀장 외 3명
레치
준비 끝!
51번 장존수
51번 bangelore
51번
51번 장존수
박팀장 외 3명
준비 끝!
왜냐하면 3명 아닙니까?
동해안 포함 아닙니까?
다시 합니다.
51 cm
50 포
51 shines
51 cm
50 포
박팀장 내 3명 배치 준비 끝
박팀장 등 외 3명
외 말고
박팀장 등 3명 배치 준비 끝
이렇게 하겠습니다
다시 한번 해주십시오
배치미 준비 끝 한 번 보고
51포 박팀장 등 3명 배치 준비 끝
좋습니다
HPD 5발 장전
저희 50포 장전수 역할을 했는데
대단히 수고 많으셨습니다
고생하셨습니다
감사합니다
박살내겠습니다
긴장이 돼서
긴장됩니다
무서워요
지금 제가 연속 포탄이었는데
진짜 포탄이었으면
땀나지 않았을 것 같아요
그래서 본인 아닙니다
진짜 멋있습니다
가시죠 박팀장
박한성 수고했어
수고 많으셨습니다
감사합니다
고생하셨습니다
세치기 하지 마신 말입니다
오늘까지만 봐줍니다
각자 먹고 싶은 대로
회식하시고 착석하시면 됩니다
슈화사님 많이 드십시오
하시면 아직 필요 없지만
자
아니 욕심이 너무 많아
표면장력 아니에요 저거?
앉으시죠 박사님
다 먹을 수 있겠습니다
맛있게 드십시오
이게 집보다 잘 나오는 것 같은데요?
자네 와이플레가 전달해주겠어
지금 촬영을 이렇게 세팅되시는데
평소에도 항상 이렇게
대해서도 최고 복지라고 하면은
음식 아니겠습니까?
윤상병 많이 먹어
잘 먹겠습니다
슈화사야 슈화사
윤상병 많이 먹게나
잘 먹겠습니다
잠깐만 아직
대리님이 아직 숟가락 안 드셨는데
아 그렇지
어디 사사님이
이거 직급에 따라 숟가락 주시는 수조가 있습니까?
좀 내려다봐 봐죠?
소령님 먼저 드십시오
먼저 드시면은
그 비관장님께서 지적 한 번 해주시면 됩니다
왜 지적을 해요?
왜 지적 그래?
아 직급별로 이거 드시는 겁니까?
뭐 그런 건 아닌데 또 선임자가 있는데
바로 먹고 싶다고
나이신이 아닙니다 군대는
모두 맛있게 드십시오
예 잘 먹겠습니다
잘 먹겠습니다
어 역시
대박에 죽는구만
우상병이 눈치가 맺잖아
자네가 눈치가 있어
아 이거 아닙니다
울려봐 진짜
되나 안 되나?
어 되나 안 되나
밥이 너무 맛있지 말입니다
진짜 맛있다 근데
연군이 굉장히 많이 보이시더라고요
이율이 어떻게 됩니까?
한 10% 정도 되는데
10%? 와
근데 어떻게 하다가 해군에 지원하게 되셨어요?
아 저는 고등학교 때
연평해전을 보고 희망을 해서 왔습니다
연평해전
어떻게 어떻게?
저는 대학교 때까지 운동을 했었는데 또
어떤 운동을 하셨어요?
사격선수를 했었는데
멋있다
아빠가 군인이었어가지고
영향을 많이 받아서
입대하게 됐습니다
와 진짜 멋있다
저희 이번에 훈련은 뭡니까?
이번에 체험하신 훈련은
신호방송소 체험인데
아까 전투대시 했을 때 나왔던
그 방송을 직접 하는 체험입니다
방송반 출신입니다
제가 방송만 10년 했습니다
와 도움이 될 것 같습니다
오늘 도와주실 조교를 모시도록 하겠습니다
안녕하십니까?
조타장 박승윤 상사입니다
일!
오늘 슈카월드 팀이 체험하실 것은
방송수 임무입니다
방송수란 함교 함장님 그리고 함교 당직사관이 지시하는 걸
승조원 청원에게 알리는 아주 중요한 임무입니다
아까 전투배치 하실 때 들으셨겠지만
우리 조타사들이 그런 방송을 실시하고 있습니다
오늘 여기 있는 방송기로 슈카월드 팀이 한번
진짜 잡고 한번 방송을 해보도록 하겠습니다
예 잘 할 수 있습니다
먼저 아까 들으셨던 전투배치
방송을 어떻게 하는지 다시 한번 보여드리겠습니다
훈련 초원 전투배치
훈련 둘 셋 전투배치
여기까지 되면 이제 모든 대원들이
전투배치란 구호를 외치면서
각자 위치로 이렇게 움직이게 되는 겁니다
혹시 저 궁금한 게 있는데
방송하실 때 특정한 어떤 억양이 있습니까?
훈련 전투배치 약간 이런 거 아닌가요?
전투배치 방송 같은 경우에는
아무래도 전투 준비를 하는 상황이기 때문에
좀 더 힘을 힘 있게
힘 있게?
더 힘 있게 정확하게 전달하기가
맞습니다
그러면 혹시 아나운서 스타일로 해도 됩니까?
안내할 수 있는 게 있습니다
아 그건 좀 아무래도 군함이니까
빨리빨리 신속하게 움직여야 돼요
예 맞습니다
간결하게
예 알겠습니다
자 먼저 누가 먼저
니하사
실제로 안 하고 그냥 시뮬레이션으로만 해보겠습니다
눌렀다 치고
훈련 전투배치
어 아닙니다
훈련하고 난 뒤에 이 경보기를 누르시고
마음속으로 3초만 있다가
이제 다 됐다고 생각하시고
다시 총원 전투배치 훈련
훈련
그렇죠
예 눌렀다 하고
눌렀다 치고
총원 전투배치
어 순서가 틀리셨습니다
이
먼저 누르고
훈련
다시 이걸 경보기가 끝나고 난 뒤에
총원 전투배치
예 알겠습니다
그리고 앞뒤로는 훈련이란 말을 좀 붙여주셔야 됩니다
누르고
전투배치!
훈련!
훈련하고
먼저 누르고 훈련하고
이 경보기를 누르고
경보기가 끝나고 난 뒤에
총원 전투배치 훈련
훈련!
전투배치!
이렇게 하시면 됩니다
아
밑에서 인원이 다 모이면
이렇게 보고를 하게 되겠습니다
아
어떡해
땀나요
아
기적같은 경우에는 저희가
추랑 만 15분전에
추랑 15분전!
추랑 15분전
그리고 원래 MOR серьез해서
다른말을 해야 되는데 그냥 기적만
A
H
아
추랑 15분전
한 번 보여드리겠습니다
추랑 15분전!
음
여기까지만 하는걸로
오 멋있어
아 잘할 수 있나 방송 경력 지금 10년차 아닙니까
제 10년에서 실수한다고
가겠습니다
화이팅
출항 15분전
네 잘하셨습니다
약간 짧게 하셨습니다
아 이게 누르면 쭉 나오는게 아니고 계속 누르고 있어야 되는 거네요
네 맞습니다
되게 짧은 감이
거의 빵
아 이런 거 해보더니
정말 존경합니다
월드팀의 방송소 체험을 마치겠습니다
감사합니다
필승
자 그래서 우리가
단합을 목적으로 제2함대
서울함에 와봤는데 어떠셨습니까
정신일도 하사불성
정신이 하나로 모이면 못할 것이 없다
그것을 체험한 하루였습니다
제가 오늘 실제로 경험을 해보니까
여러분들이
확실히 모범 병사는 아닌 것 같다
라는 생각을 하게 됩니다
관심이 필요합니다
문장 외우는 것 빼고 다 잘하거든요
우리 박하사가
56번 장전수
그거를 한 4번 반복하는 걸 보면서
머리만 좋으신데
56번 장전수 8글자인데 그게 안 외워져
여기가 서해
NRA를 수호하는
우리 제2함대
서울함이라고 할 수 있습니다
말 그대로 적과 교부할 수 있는 그런 함대인데
특별히 저희한테 들어오는 걸
허락해 줬습니다
좋은 경험하고
나라사랑 우리 해군양병 여러분들이
수고하고 고생하는지
알 수 있는 시간이 아닌가 생각합니다
자 이제 조심해서 내려가보도록 하겠습니다
오늘 저희가 세 분께서 알고 보니까
군대를 제대로 나오시는 분이 없다
무슨 소리야 무슨 소리 지금
화나게 하네
나 어렸을 때 계롱대에서
나 해병대 지원했어